there are a load of civilians who are
being evacuated now from a frontline
area who um you can see they're mostly
old uh
women and men um who've just been taken
out of an area
how are you feeling
you speak english
children as well
these are the the children who've been
coming under shelling and bombardment
hi hello sir do you speak english
they're all um clearly very traumatized
if i show you what they've been running
from this is the area that they've been
running from it's the town of urban
which is about eight kilometers away
from the capital kiev and you can see
a large amount of smoke and whatever in
the background we've heard a lot of
outgoing artillery
because they're trying to
stop the advancing um troops and we're
not sure exactly what's going on in
there because the soldiers
there's
the soldiers are um they've lost our
picture at the moment if you can try and
sort that but i'll carry on talking
because i believe you can hear me
there's a lot going on in in urban
and
and um we're back and uh
they have been tried they've been
ferrying out civilians large numbers of
civilians you can hear there's a lot of
action
artillery in going and outgoing um from
uh european that's outgoing that big
boom
they suspect these are part of the
russian
troops who are trying to get to the
capital were very close to the capital
it's only taken us about half an hour if
you didn't have multiple checkpoints it
would take you far less time we know
that there are a substantial number of
civilians still trapped in that town who
are trying to get out
we've seen a number of them
walking out some being ferried out
ambulances coming out
there's a
large number of um ukrainian soldiers
that we've seen some who came out who
said they come from butcher that's
another area that's beyond it's fine
it's fine it's okay um there's a number
of uh
we know that there are a number of
reports coming from butcher
where there is um they are also being
shelled butcher is um to the north
east if you like of of urban
we know that there is action
fighting explosions shelling going on in
both butcher and earp in here and i
think that those who are under attack in
butcher
are forced to come through this town
open so this is and this is also
you can hear substantial
shelling and rocket fire we've been
speaking to
a number of um ukrainian soldiers
a number of ukrainian politicians just
this morning one who joined up the uh
the territorial army as many of them
have
absolutely urgently demanding more
international
uh participation in this in the way of a
a no-fly zone we heard the the president
the ukrainian president overnight
and this morning he's been on on
television again this morning um
appealing to the international community
and nato to impose a no-fly zone because
they believe
that this is the only way that they're
going to be able to
to stop
the the advancing russian troops we know
that um
there's a huge number of russian troops
uh it's satellite images have shown it's
40 mile long
with a tankers fuel tankers
a large number of troops several
thousand troops who have been sitting on
the north of of um
of the capital for the past four days
according to us and uk
intelligence
[Music]
there's a lot going on in the center of
a veropin at the moment
this has really picked up in the last
couple of hours because
earlier on this morning when we
when we were intending to go into
um
the center
we were
told that it was it was possible to get
in to the center from our
military contacts and um obviously
that's completely changed in the last
few hours and many of the ukrainians
who've been coming out of urban
and butcher have been demanding that
there's some sort of humanitarian
corridor agreed
[Music]
because
where all that noise is coming from
where all that military sound that
you're hearing there are civilians there
at the end of that
terrified civilians the the
look these are some of them that have
just come out um
again there's a small gaggle of of of um
journalists here um
who are who are trying to get into the
city to talk to some of the civilians
and these are the coaches that they're
being taken out on
um
let's just take a quick look inside
before
just to get a quick yes does anyone
speak english here yeah hi how what was
it like in there where you've just come
from urban or somewhere else we were on
a circle uh
like you know when you're gone
okay
don't worry okay they're very stressed
tell me quickly are you all right i'm
all right and how many people are
trapped in there
legalized 420
american
appreciation british british
how many more legalizing great britain
is
cannabis legalized i don't know whether
cannabis is licensed i'm glad that's all
you're thinking about how many civilians
are still there do you think uh i think
not many
those
who can't
like you know defend themselves right
there but there are still substantial
civilians there
look you can see they're in a
traumatized state very often very
the ukrainians are strong people he's
asking are you all right sir
they've got very red faces they're
looking very upset because
they know that they're uh
they're lucky to be alive frankly
um
even the most
glory to ukraine that's what um a lot of
that and still more vehicles are going
back in to try and pick people up
travel safe
thanks bless you okay
um
i was saying that there's obviously a
substantial amount of military action
going on
in there that is outgoing so they're
trying to push them back they're trying
to keep them there they're trying to
hold them back
um
and uh
you can hear you can you can hear the
other languages because of the the
international um correspondence who are
here um we're all oh look you can see
outgoing rockets and flares
[Music]
that seems to me like it's getting
closer
but they're still desperately trying to
take civilians out of
the combat zone
seems to have gone a bit quiet i can see
actually
um
vehicles not too far away one that's
just left here who's trying to trying to
pick up civilians there who've managed
to make their way there
is that a military vehicle jake that you
can see
it looked like beyond the humvee there
was there was a military vehicle doing
maneuvers
and there's still a row of coaches here
waiting they're obviously expecting more
civilians to come out or hoping here
comes another another two vehicles so
any civilians who've managed to make it
to this far they're trying they're
trying to pick up
and beyond that it's difficult to judge
the distances in this case but beyond
that there i would say maybe half a mile
you could see big
mushroom of of cloud where there's
obviously been some
some explosions
here come some more some more civilians
coming out
it sounds like there's almost
um street by street fighting because we
can hear
um arms fire
arms fire
we're obviously going to be monitoring
this situation which is still very
active throughout throughout the rest of
the day and this morning and we'll bring
you any updates but right at the moment
there is a
an active
what appears to be fighting going on in
urban which is only eight kilometers
from uh the ukrainian capital and
they've been more and more urgent
appeals from ukrainian politicians the
ukrainian people for a no-fly zone to be
imposed and for urgently in a
humanitarian corridor to be agreed
between the fighting sides so that the
civilians who are trapped
inside that town
um can be rescued we'll keep you up to
date throughout the day
alex alex crawford there please keep
safe